[Music]
a somber looking president putin in his
home city of saint petersburg to mark
the end of the devastating siege of
leningrad as the city was known then in
world war ii
now it is up to him to take the steps
necessary to avoid another large-scale
war on european soil
the documents handed into russia's
foreign ministry on wednesday by the u.s
ambassador are now on putin's desk but
already the sense in moscow that they
don't go far enough
there is a reaction there that allows us
to expect a serious dialogue to begin
but on secondary issues there is no
positive reaction on the main issue
in this document the main issue is our
clear position on the inadmissibility of
further expansion of nato to the east
and the deployment of strike weapons
that could threaten the territory of the
russian federation
nato is a defensive alliance the one
concept the kremlin just can't or won't
accept
and so we wait for president putin's
verdict and the next high-level
ministerial contact diplomacy still
underway but so too are the preparations
for war or what looks very much like it
the video drops from russia's ministry
of defense keep coming
drills here there and everywhere from
russian naval ships firing in the baltic
sea to russian fighter jets landing in
belarus
the official line is that these are
russian military exercises on russian or
belarusian soil nothing to see here
while the subtext screams look at this
in ukraine's east soldiers who've known
war for years walk the trenches of this
snowy front line
and as far west as lev civilians train
in the skills of military combat
ukraine is pushing hard for the west to
present a united front
this crisis is always a moment of truth
and this is why we speak about weapons
this is why we speak about economic
sanctions this is why we speak about the
consolidated position of all of us that
so that president putin sees that there
are no weak links
in the
uh
in in our defensive chain
this as more nato fighter jets arrive on
its eastern flank
exactly what russia objects to but what
it will see more and more of until and
unless it backs down dynamic day sky
news moscow